[Music]
so I think a lot about this relationship
between beauty aesthetic works and
catharsis and at what price
[Music]
the philosopher Alain de Botton had an
amazing passage in his book the
architecture of happiness in which he
described an individual being so moved
by a work of art that he was shaken to
tears he was literally bawling because
he was so affected by the outrageous
beauty emanating from the work that he
was looking at and you know the
imaginary foundation define beauty as
this kind of rousing symphonic climax
you know it's explosive through the
strawberry moment of poetry and grace
but again at what price
and I recently came across an actual
affliction called the Stendhal syndrome
this is an actual psychosomatic
condition an actual medical condition in
which an individual can be so moved by
an aesthetic work a work of art can
effective so deeply that he can
literally lose consciousness the
individual can literally pass out from
the aesthetic impact of a work of art
[Applause]
how far are we willing to go to make
beautiful art can beautiful art
destroyed you know the artist has to ask
himself this question all the time like
at what right you know can you have too
much ecstasy
[Music]
how far are we willing to go to have
that catharsis you know even if it kills
us can we be destroyed by arts by our
own arts I guess that's the question
[Music]
you